♪♪
-All right,
so I mimed Ron DeSantis
eating pudding with two fingers.
He allegedly eats pudding
with three fingers.
[ Light laughter ]
Two fingers for yogurt.
[ Laughter ]
Graveyards are attached to ch--
I've been conflating
graveyards and cemeteries,
and there's a difference.
Graveyards are attached
to churches.
Cemeteries are attached
to highways.
[ Laughter ]
I've always thought
there was something funny --
when you see an old church
and there's just one of those
tiny, little graveyards
that, at some point in 1740,
someone said,
"I think that
will be big enough."
[ Laughter ]
"I think that will be big enough
for everybody forever."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckling ]
"Unless something bad happens."
Oh, Cars for Kids.
We all know
the Cars for Kids commercial.
It's got that catchy song --
you know, herpes catchy,
but catchy.
And...
[ Laughter ]
I believed
it to be a regional ad.
I guess it's gone national now.
And I always said, if we didn't
stop them when we had a chance,
this would happen.
Um.
Got a chance to do
my Rupert Murdoch impression
a few times this week...
with our now pretty famous
catchphrase,
[Australian accent]
"Eat bugs, ya [bleep]!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Really unfortunate things
have been happening.
The closed captioning,
in parentheses,
has been saying
"Austrian accent."
[ Laughter ]
Which must be very jarring
for those who aren't hearing it,
who wonder why I'm giving
an Austrian accent
to Rupert Murdoch.
First of all,
it wouldn't sound like that.
I mean, if he'd been Austrian,
like -- I don't know --
Just pick an...
Austrian name out of a hat --
Christoph Waltz.
[ Laughter ]
So it would sound like...
[Austrian accent]
"Eat bugs, Mr. Bond!"
[ Normal voice ]
So different.
Okay. So, we showed a clip
of Tucker Carlson
discussing testicle tanning.
And none of these
are my errors --
they are Tucker's.
But he's in a tough spot
right now.
He doesn't have a show
to address his mistakes.
So this is a situation where --
next man up,
I'm going to jump in the fray
here, do him a solid.
And testicle tanning
is a really bad idea.
If you want to do it at all,
which you probably shouldn't,
you're going to want
to do scrotum tanning
because...
the testicles are inside.
There's no --
[ Laughter ]
The sun would have to be so hot
to get through the --
again, to use a Shoemaker term,
scrotal wall.
[ Laughter ]
Or you'd do a whole --
you'd take them out,
and then you've got to put them
back in once you toast them up.
And that's,
to use a medical term,
like, just a whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
I said "a-lleg-ed."
It's "alle-ged."
Or at least
that's what they claimed.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
I said zoologists blew it
with the spelling of "zoologist"
because they just
should have put --
if there was ever a time
to put a three O's in a row,
that would be it, right?
You got the "zoo" part
and you got the "ology."
Just don't shorten it.
Be the one word with three O's.
Well...there is already a word
with three O's in a row --
pardon my pronunciation --
"hysterosalpingo-oophorectomy,"
which is a word
that means "hat."
[ Laughter ]
So, you guys, it is --
I've been giving you
some false information.
It is a little worse
to look at an eclipse,
because what happens is, when
the sun goes behind the moon,
the eye dilates to adjust
for the lack of light.
And then, so when the sun
pokes back out again,
your eyes aren't ready for it.
And so that is
when you get blasted there.
That is why it's worse
for you to look.
The eclipse isn't
the bad moment --
it's when the sun
starts coming back out.
Your eyes aren't ready for it.
Interesting fact, though --
that's the only sunlight.
That moment
where it first comes out,
that's the only sunlight
hot enough
to permeate the scrotal wall.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about
how Trump wanted a --
wanted the mug shot
because he thought
it would be a cool thing.
And then we said, "Hey,
don't make this one of those" --
You know,
like the Johnny Cash mug shot
where, all of a sudden,
it's on a poster
and people are hanging it
in their dorm rooms,
because nobody wants to,
you know, go in,
and you flip on a lava lamp,
and then all of a sudden, you
see a Trump poster on the wall.
Well, some lava lamp owners gave
us the news that you never --
when you flip on a lava lamp,
it's not light.
It takes like 45 minutes
to get going.
So that was a bad example
of a lamp.
It's why you've never seen --
there's never been
that cinematic scene in a movie
where someone walks
into a dark room,
and then, like,
a lamp gets flipped on
to reveal someone
waiting for them.
It's never a lava lamp.
[ Laughter ]
They never, like, open the room,
and hear, like, click --
"Surprised to see me?"
And it's like, "I can't see --
What? Hello?"
"Oh, son of a gun.
Is this a lava lamp?"
[ Laughter ]
"Mm.
Well, it's your ex-wife
who you thought was dead."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you know, we did a surprise
inspection this week.
And Ally Hord,
our wonderful writer --
Ally Hord had a joke
about Watson and Crick
and their discovery
of the double helix.
Many of you pointed out it would
be a mistake to credit them
and not also credit British
chemist Rosalind Franklin.
So I reached out to Ally,
and I said, "You know,
a lot of people think
Rosalind Franklin
also deserves praise
for that discovery.
And do you know -- do you know
what Ally said to me?
"A woman scientist?
I don't think so."
[ Laughter ]
It was my mistake.
Ally -- Ally's joke did not
actually say the double helix
when I was busting on it.
And so it was -- I was the one
who erred there, not Ally.
I did a -- I did James Corden.
Our friend James Corden
had his last show --
I guess, depending
on when you watch this,
either today or --
or yesterday
or three weeks from now.
Is that how it works?
[ Laughs ]
He had his final show,
and I did it last week.
I'd never done it.
I had a wonderful time.
And, you know, obviously, we --
you know, now sour grapes here,
but "Corrections" has,
a couple of times now,
lost to "Carpool Karaoke"
in its Emmy category.
And so, you know,
I was there with him.
I thought I'd ask
for a little bit of advice --
you know,
"How can we break through?"
And he said, you know,
"One of the nice things
about 'Carpool Karaoke' is we
have, you know, the star power.
We have guests who give it
a little bit of pop."
And I said,
"Oh, man, that would be great.
Do you think, like,
Adele would do 'Corrections'?"
And he said, "Yeah, you know,
you should ask her."
And I said,
"Do you have her number?"
And he was like, "Uh, yeah."
And I was like, "Great."
He goes, "Do you have a pen?"
I was like, "Yep."
And -- And then --
I didn't realize till I left
because he goes,
"Here it is --
1-877-K-A..."
[ Laughter ]
We talked about the Stevie Nicks
song "White Winged Dove."
Many of you had long thought
the lyric was "one-winged dove."
I then pointed out
that a one-winged dove
would just, you know,
sort of fly in circles.
Um.
A bunch of you pointed out
I was mistaken --
I was mistaking what would
happen to a bird with one wing
to what would happen to a boat
with one paddle
because a boat with one paddle
would just go in circles,
and a dove with one wing
would die real fast.
[ Laughter ]
Um.
Jackal jokes.
And every now and then,
the Jackals send in jokes.
We were talking about, again,
this Tucker Carlson story,
how Fox News has supposedly been
keeping an oppo file against him
and how that
doesn't seem like a --
I said, "I don't think
H.R. would approve
if NBC kept an oppo file on me
and any of our staff."
And...someone said
it would be hard
for NBC H.R. to blackmail Wally
because, when it comes to H.R.,
Wally is laying low.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't even get this one
right away.
So, we talked about
Lindsey Graham's meemaw
feeding shrimp to the chickens.
And someone wrote --
And then we said,
you know, because you wouldn't
feed shrimp to chickens.
So someone wrote, "Chickens
eat any and everything,
but never give them bok choy.
I gave some
to our chickens one time
and they still won't
shut up about it."
[ Light laughter ]
Do you get it, Shoemaker?
Bok, bok, bok!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know,
it's a thinker,
but, you know...
it's structurally sound.
[ Light laughter ]
Someone else wrote,
"Do chickens ever eat anything
and think,
'Mmm, tastes like me'?"
[ Laughter ]
I didn't -- These --
You can't be mad at me.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Clicking ]
Um.
We talked about a funeral coach
and how I was on
the varsity funeral team in --
in high school.
It was a bit.
[ Laughter ]
But -- And hold on,
because this is...
I'm going to get real.
Someone said, "I don't believe
Seth was ever
a varsity athlete."
Well, I was.
In fact, one year,
I lettered in track on our --
Sorry. I lettered on our varsity
track team in high school.
Track -- a cool thing about
track in my high school
was the only sport
you couldn't get cut from.
But this is --
Now, this is not a correction.
This is just
a true story about --
track was the only sport
I did in high school,
but I did -- my junior year,
I decided to go out
for the football team,
and the reason I waited
until my junior year
is my brother was a freshman,
and my brother decided to go out
for football as a freshman,
which is the correct time
to start going out for a sport.
And I don't -- it was --
some sort of sibling-rivalry
thing kicked in
because I never assumed
the Meyers boys
were going to be
high-school football players.
But as soon as my brother
decided he was going to do it,
I just had to do it.
And I knew the coach of
our high-school football team.
His son and I
had grown up together.
We were friends.
And so I went and saw him,
and I said,
"I want to go out
for the football team."
And he said, "Don't --
please don't come out
for the football team.
You're never going to play.
It's going to be a massive
waste of your time.
I'm going to make you start
with the JV kids,
so you're going to be spending
all your practices
with freshman and sophomore."
And I was like, "I don't care.
I'm going to take this on.
I appreciate that I made
a mistake waiting,
but this is very
important to me."
And he said,
"Please don't do this.
Please don't do this."
And I said,
"I'm going to do it."
And he goes,
"Well, I can't tell you not to."
And so, that summer,
I did two-a-day practices --
the worst time to participate
in football -- in August,
and I did it
for the full two weeks.
I should note my brother
made it two days before he quit.
So the reason I was doing it
just walked out the door,
and I was like,
"I'm going to stick with it,"
because I knew, if I went home,
my dad would call me a quitter.
But when your younger brother
goes home, they're like,
"He's whimsical."
[ Laughter ]
Two weeks -- Two weeks
of two-a-day practices.
Then it's the last day
of the summer,
and I walk in,
I get on my full --
This is a true story.
This a very
traumatic story for me.
I get in my full football gear.
And then
the assistant coach says,
"Coach wants to talk to you."
And I go into
the coach's office,
and he says, "I'm cutting you
from the football team."
And I, for real, did not think
that was a possibility.
And I said, "You're cutting me
from the football team?"
He goes, "I just can't do this.
I can't in good faith
have you waste all your time."
He said, "I just feel like
you have other talents."
And I said, "You -- I can't
believe you're doing that.
I can't believe
you wasted two weeks."
And he goes, "I do apologize.
I should have
done it right away.
You seemed so committed
to this idea,
but I am cutting you
from the football team."
And then I had to walk through
a locker room full of guys
and then change
out of my football uniform
and then walk out
in street clothes.
And that's -- it's a significant
difference in outfits.
Everyone know-- Even the dumbest
kid on the team was like,
"Oh, something
just happened here."
So...
[ Laughter ]
And people
talked about it forever.
No one had been cut
from the football team
until I had been cut
from the football team,
and everybody knew about it.
They -- And they were friends.
I had friends
on the football team.
I then later -- you know,
we had superlatives
in our high-school yearbook.
I'm very happy to say I was
Best Sense of Humor
in our high-school
superlatives.
And I remember
a football player said,
"You know, I voted for you."
And I said, "Thank you."
And he said,
"I just thought it was so funny
when you got cut
from the football team."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway,
I held a grudge for so long
about the football coach
having put me through that
because it was -- I mean, again,
as traumas go, it's nothing --
but it really --
it really did stick with me
for years and years.
Anyway, you know,
15 years later, I'm on "SNL."
I get asked to go back to my
high school to talk to the kids.
And I'm walking
down the hallway,
and the football coach
is now the guidance counselor.
And I'm walking
down the hallway,
and I'm still mad at him,
and I see him
coming the other way.
And he sees me,
and he just points at me.
And he said, "I told you
you had other talents!"
[ Laughter ]
And I realized he'd been right
the whole time.
I wasn't supposed
to play football.
I was supposed to do
the other thing.
I still iced him in the hallway.
[ Laughter ]
No, I know.
Because, you guys, football --
my talents were not football.
My talents are not
even a plural.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm good at one thing,
which is writing,
and I love writing so much.
I really do.
And, you know,
I would do it for free.
Some might say
writing "Corrections"
is doing it for free.
[ Laughter ]
You might notice Pizza Hut's...
...sponsorship ended at one.
[ Laughter ]
I am deeply proud of the fact
that I get to be
a professional writer,
and I bring this up because,
as of Monday at midnight,
there might be
a writers' strike.
And if a writers' strike
happens,
that would shut down production
on a great many shows.
And...I've been through this
before in 2007, 2008.
There was a very long strike
when I was working at "SNL,"
and it was really miserable.
And it doesn't just affect
the writers,
it affects all the incredible
non-writing staff
on these shows.
And it would really be
a miserable thing
for people
to have to go through,
especially considering we're on
the heels of that awful pandemic
that affected obviously not just
show business, but all of us.
And so I'm incredibly grateful
that there are negotiators
for both sides
sitting and talking.
I'm incredibly hopeful that
they can come to an agreement.
I also feel very strongly that
what the writers are asking for
is not unreasonable.
And, as a proud member
of the Guild,
I'm very grateful
that there is an organization
that looks out for
the best interests of writers.
So if you don't see me here
next week,
know that it is something that
is not done lightly
and that I will be heartbroken,
too, and miss you, as well.
And let's just keep
our you-know-whats...
and see me when you see me.